hello I'm Chris hey Doc and i'm here at
the wolfram technology conference
talking about the elephant in the room
and that's the Wolfram cloud it's uh and
I'm giving my little piece of the
elephant which is what the Wolfram cloud
looks like to the kind of ramen noodle
developer set that is those who have web
who have some sort of web business which
makes enough revenue to buy a pack of
ramen noodles every day
okay so back in July when you know I had
a lot of idle time like I'm sure all the
rest you do and I thought you know well
somebody should really say something
about the cloud from the perspective of
the user so here I am now okay so you
know I've been i guess there's been a
lot of cloud talk in the lat you know
certainly in the last two years last
year's presentation the year before I
think the year before it's fair to say
people who are kind of really puzzled
about what the cloud was and you know
last year you could see some people
begin to understand what the cloud was
and I think you know this year we've
come to the point where you know the
understanding of the cloud of the
wolfram cloud I'm talking about of
course it's beginning to mature a little
bit to where you actually like talk to
people and you have the impression that
quite a few people understand what's
going on with a cloud ah but it's a work
definitely a work in progress and we're
still kind of at the early stages where
I think it would be fair to say that the
cloud is still kind of like an elephant
in the room you know there's like
different people have different
viewpoints of different parts of the
cloud and your quickly discover here as
I talk that I definitely have you know
my own particular elephant view of what
the elephant is and I'm going to talk
about that and I certainly uh you know
would encourage anybody you know as I'm
talking about this who has a different
impression did you know chime in and and
you know say okay well I see this little
differently so I've I say I got a few
slides here they might be I just gave
the notebook over there in the setup
room it may be on the website yet I'm
not sure it's not there now it should be
there momentarily
okay so okay so how did I kind of
develop my perspective of the cloud i
think i just want to give a little
background on that okay so a question
that comes up is obviously you know well
what can i do with a Wolfram cloud and
and they're beginning to be talks about
what you can do with the Wolfram cloud
which are pretty interesting and just
looking on the Wolfram community and
looking on you know Mathematica stack
exchange you know you see also people
asking questions both very simple
questions which show that they haven't
got a clue what the cloud is or how it
works two questions which show the
people have pretty deep understanding of
you know web application frameworks and
they're trying to figure out how to fit
in you know the Wolfram cloud and you
know the workflows that they're familiar
with so anyway I you know don't come at
it from well I sort of cuz I come out
from somewhere kind of in between you
know I don't have a lot of web
development experience but you know
starting two years ago it looked like
there could be some really interesting
things it can be done with a cloud and
I'd certainly have to say that at that
point two years ago I mean and I and
probably a lot of people were kind of
naive maybe about what you could do with
the cloud and how much work it would
take yeah because here I am you know two
years later I've been you know putting
significant time in this and you know
I'm still really trying to figure out
you know what can I do with the cloud
yeah how to do them okay so I and and I
would say that okay so how does the
cloud okay so obviously the cloud is
something wolfin research building and
obviously the cloud has to generate
revenue so you can pay developers to
build it so that explains presumably a
lot of what we see about how the cloud
is developing because somebody you know
you what haven't entered
rise cloud where you have you know
enterprise clients who can pay good
money to you know for services in the
Wolfram cloud which can you know finance
developing the cloud both as a more you
know for people who aren't enterprises
like probably a lot of people in this
room aren't anyway so see what I want to
say here so you know as always I you
know I've worked on all kinds of
different computing projects and of
course there are bugs right and so you
see a bug and long experience says that
you want to know something about how the
system you're using works you know in
order to fix it okay okay so let's let's
just stop it the basic idea in the cloud
is this right you have so for decades
we've been using the front end you know
since the beginning of time in
Mathematica and basically that's you
know creating this notebook
representation which is like easy to
interact with so you know with the
advance of evict web technology the
obvious idea is well gee we don't have
to have the front end sitting on our
desktop but we can have like something
that looks like a front end sitting in
the cloud so that anybody anywhere can
access it and and and this is like an
easy idea to think of but it's you know
probably a more difficult idea to
execute especially when you get to the
point where if you think about it like
there's okay so there's this wolfram
development platform which one is which
is this cloud thing which one uses to
develop cloud application so the level
of complexity is something like if two
decades ago right when the front end was
introduced people it said okay we've got
this front end and maybe we could use it
uh to develop other front ends because I
mean that's sort of
algis to what's happening is happening
here we got this not only is there a way
of representing things in the cloud but
there's this wolfram development
platform which allows kind of
effectively other people to make other
front ends using the Wolfram cloud so
it's it's kind of inherently more
complex okay so uh okay so we all will
like to look at code so i was at johns
talk yesterday and he was gracious
enough yesterday to last night after
talk to kind of explain to me enough so
i could kind of understand how you know
the little web development thing which
which i just want to talk about here
briefly as an example okay so oops i
know this is going to do that to me okay
wait a minute I didn't want to do that
okay let me try that again actually let
me not go to the website let me just say
in a few words what what the thing is
here so when you go to the github site
which you know John directed to us
yesterday you'll see this little icon
below here a sort of view notebooks
actually went went up he went there you
saw the icon but when I went there I
didn't see the icon apparently because
there's some privilege issue and anyway
so i was looking at this last night and
ok so i have a theory about how you
would change the privileges but that's
based upon you know developing a picture
of how this whole thing works you know
what well you know there's a cloud and
you start out you're at the github
website and then there's some URL that
sends you to the Wolfram cloud and and
that develops an index of notebooks you
can look at and so the icon for those
notebooks works but this icon doesn't
work but they both have the same
privileges privilege but you know based
upon having looked at this probably
what's happening is when this icon shows
up on github it's like going like
directly to Wolfram cloud and
downloading the image and it's like
finding that it's
you know a private object that it can't
download it whereas when it goes to
Wolfram cloud and makes an index page
and it displays an icon the browser is
not going directly to walk from cloud to
get the icon there's some like
JavaScript trickery that's happening
where the image is being loaded by
JavaScript and that's probably why the
privileges for this icon and the
notebook icon are different about anyway
let me move on here I belabor that point
enough so a lot of it in response to you
know again things I was seeing on the
Wolfram community people ask you know
kind of well what could you do with the
Wolfram cloud I started well obviously
the place to do is is okay so this has
now been out for a year of Arnold's
flavor rater thing so and there's a
whole bunch of other examples there's
tweet a program there's the Wolfram pi
day they're all like web sites built in
the cloud with Wolfram technology and
and so you know an obvious thing to do
when you're going to develop on these
websites is well you go to these you
know to go to some of these websites
that we were all advertising the Wolfram
community on stack exchanged and you
look at them to see if they're similar
if there might be similar to something
that you're interested in doing so
that's exactly what I did and uh and you
know for whatever reason okay i guess
because i'm kind of like interesting in
code and stuff i started you know
looking deeper and I started wondering
well what can I do what can I learn
about okay saurons first flavor writer
uses form function okay and so when you
go to flavor a turn you you get a site
that looks like i have just a little
small addition here it's a form function
right so
yeah the client at least the question
naturally occurs to me and again this is
my little you know my view of the
elephant here is like you say okay what
could I do like the flavor raters just
this little kind of application it you
know it doesn't do it's just like in
terms of what my ambition is to build a
website i myself but the flavor rater
sits in the context of the Wolfram cloud
and in particular it's generated by this
engine that makes representations of
notebooks and again this is one of those
things you just have to try I mean I'm
really not sure even at this point how
successful or how fruitful this line of
inquiry is but you say okay what can I
learn about the engine sitting back here
in the cloud and about cloud technology
that might give me a clue about how to
develop cloud websites by looking at the
you know HTML and style script and more
importantly the JavaScript that is
generating this site so anyways some
months ago I spent quite a bit of time
you know looking at that to see what I
could discover and so anyway on my to-do
list you know in all my idle time is to
write a knife's Wolfram community post
about what I learned by looking at the
JavaScript that is downloaded when a
form function displays on the web so
obviously I haven't done that yet
because if I had I'd just be like
directing you to the website instead of
doing this talk but I would like to talk
there are some interesting things you
can learn so you know first obviously
and go to sweat page you could say show
source code and then voila there's the
short source code it's just this little
short page and it's got pretty standard
looking at HTML stuff and then you know
down at the bottom it's downloading some
JavaScript so you can go and you can
download the java script and now of
course the javascript is just looks like
a horrendous mess so you have to
beautify the javascript and that puts it
into lines that you can then read and
try to make sense of and again I you
know I
again it's on my to do is to write like
a sensible community post about what I
discovered but i can give you kind of a
short answer so you I don't even
remember exactly i mean it's somewhere
like the javascript it does this is
somewhere between like ten thousand a
hundred thousand lines okay you know
enough to discourage the casual observer
but um you know if you just start
searching for you know text strings in
it what you can find out is that it's a
bunch of packages and maybe you know ten
or twenty percent of that is probably
code that was written at Wolfram
research and you know the rest of it is
packages like code mirror which is this
JavaScript package that enables you to
display code and things on a web page
you know and they're in again on top of
my head I'm not going to be able to list
all the packages but you can see like
half a dozen packages that were made up
approximately eighty or ninety percent
of this JavaScript you know which you
can then go on the web and you can read
about to find out how they work and
again you can also look at the ten or
twenty percent that looks like custom
Wolfram research written code you can
then guess okay here's probably what
this is doing so anyway bottom line okay
I want to leave a few minutes here to
talk about this is that what I learned
from doing this is that if at this stage
if you want to build you know a more
let's say ambitious website or you know
a kind of quote real website um and I
think that's kind of worn out by the
talks you know I haven't a time because
it always happens when you're doing a
talk you're like not having a lot of
time to go to talks before your own talk
but I get the impression that you know a
lot this is some of the successful
things that we're starting here about
our are these more hybrid things where
they're using these web application
frameworks and then they're somehow
figuring out some clever way to use
Wolfram language tools within it so this
hybrid thing is then you know creating a
more interesting real website let me let
me see what my next slide is here okay
so yeah anyway so this is ya know now
part of what I'm talking about here
right good this is timing is working out
good here okay so and I've lost my train
of thought here just a second ok so
anyway bottom line you know it's
probably what you want to do is think of
some mixture of a web application frame
Mike and Wolfram language tools to
create you know your projects now ok so
maybe maybe I'll just kind of wrap up
here well I put up some questions here
you know one of the interesting kind of
business type ideas like think about is
is there a path from like ramen noodle
profitability to like Wolfram enterprise
cloud right because a lot of us we know
we're like you know we're like in the
ramen noodle class okay we're making
enough you know you've got some some
online websites and things that are
making enough reps revenue to by ramen
noodles like you know you know a daily
supply you know and that's like a long
way obviously from you know really
plugging into the Wolfram enterprise
crowd so uh I think this is you know
this isn't question and and just again
looking from the Wolfram community
different kind of social media where
coders and things people who are
developing websites talk you know you
can see that I mean it's not always
explicitly stated but this is kind of a
question in the background ok so I
briefly want to say and uh ok first of
all look I'm sorry does anybody have
like a question now because I don't want
to talk to like the very end and and not
give people an opportunity for questions
I have some more things to talk about
intercepting code but if somebody wants
to ask a question I just want to give
people a chance to ask a question
oh okay you're talking about the the
sendmail issue okay so there's that link
is the bull from community post that i
did about this unfortunately it is
broken with version 11 as far as i know
and i haven't had time to try to figure
out well I sort of know why but it's
like you know in the ideal world I would
have reported a bug and right away
somebody Wolfram worse research would
have fixed it but you know in the real
world you know these things take time
and right now arm you know it's probably
possible to this but you'd have to like
dig in and well okay actually the code
will work as it is you and I think the
example will still work because it uses
URL exit fetch which is now been kind of
kicked off the cliff okay it's not going
to be the way to do things anymore
because there's this better thing you I
guess it's what URL read and there's
this new thing which looks really cool
which is called HTTP request so you are
read cause you know does this
httprequest object and that all looks
really nice and it's going to be really
cool once it all works but like I said I
I don't think it's actually working too
well right now least that's my
impression that um and that second link
is actually you can read some comments
about whether or not it works okay and
you can take them with us a bigger grain
of salt as you like years again this is
a work in progress not sure but so that
first thing the Wolfram community posts
that will actually work but you'll have
to use the URL fetch and as far as I
know the URL read doesn't work and let's
see i have two minutes here let me let
me just say that okay so ideally like
there'd be some Wolfram language thing
we're okay you're trying to do HTTP
requests and somehow the Wolfram
language looks that it can look down at
a low enough level it's a traffic and
figure out so you can debug
whether you're HTTP request works and
you know i'm not i know i'm sure in
principle as possible do that but it
seems like right now it's easier to use
set up a proxy server again in my spare
time sometime i'd like to write a
community post about how to set up a
proxy server to monitor HTTP traffic you
know if you're in the business it's like
obvious and you know i'm not in the
business took me you know some time to
figure out how to do it but it would be
nice to have a post because to actually
like again it's these things and working
with the web it's it's more complex you
you know you're not the cloud you got
the desktop there's communities go in
between and it's like it doesn't work on
your laptop there and you're trying to
figure out where it's not working it's
very useful to look at the traffic so
anyway i have the link there two men in
the middle proxy which is a really good
way and the other nice thing about it is
you know if you look at the traffic and
it doesn't look right and and you know
you can use this proxy server has like
an editor in it so you can tell it okay
when this piece of traffic comes through
and it has you know this little it's
lacking this little tag or something you
can tell it to edit in the tag and then
you know it's you know it intercepts a
thing it Wiggles it around how you told
it and then it sends it on and therefore
that's an easy way to verify that you
actually understand what the problem is
you know that you're experiencing you
know in your kind of server to server
communication so anyway again in the
ideal world would be I would have
written a blog post about this but I
haven't yet but anyway there are the
basic links and you can figure out
certainly anybody who wants to try this
I'd be happy to help them and in the
meantime before I get to this blog post
I tended intend to write about it so
anyway I'll close there and just acid
and thank you and I just you know want
to also say in concluding that I I think
I just appreciate your coming because
you know I think it shows that you know
there's there's a lot of people thinking
about issues related to this and just
the fact that you showed up you know
kind of is encouraging that you know
like next year somebody will do version
2 point 0 of this talk and it'll be a
lot more informative
then this kind of version 1 point 0 that
I'm doing right now thank you